what up everyone
welcome to episode 27 of coffee and
commerce
as always most of the time actually
we've got our
chairman and ceo of vaynerx gary
vaynerchuk with us
hello everyone and today we've got the
reverential
brilliant a true gentleman incredibly
successful gentleman
brandon cohen the founder of liquid iv
thanks for joining us brandon
yeah thanks for having me excited to be
here real quick uh
zubin i apologize but the chat is off
and running i need to address two things
that were chatted about right before we
started
christian reza please tell your wife i'm
sorry she doesn't like me my stance on
college actually is not that extreme
it's a very narrow stance which is
there's so many kids that
collect debt for a diploma that isn't
practical in a 2021 world
and i think a lot of people should go to
college especially if their parents pay
for it or if it's a full ride it's a fun
vacation
um but yes i think things are changing
and i apologize i want to meet her
following up to that point when he said
my wife thinks doesn't like garyvee
because of
the college thing 1995 yuta said garyvee
thinks he's better than other people
he's a douchebag of course your wife
hates his guts
ironically please do not confuse my
conviction
for my belief that i think i'm better as
a matter of fact it's the reverse i
actually think i mean nothing
and that if i die tomorrow i'll have 12
hours of good talk on
twitter brandon will say that i was a
good mentor and said a couple smart
things
zoobeen will say i was did it but like i
believe i mean
nothing but i have conviction in what i
believe and i'm sure that comes across
sometimes yada
as that i think i'm better i actually
think i'm worse
on the record uh bc good to see you bro
zoom being sorry just
it was fun the comments part of coffee
and commerce is my favorite part
but what what my second favorite part is
is the guests
and this young man and if you're
watching this very handsome young man
has pulled off one of the great
executions in direct to consumer
in the last decade and deserves the
floor and uh
and i'm excited about that and i know
zubin you can ask the best question so
here we go
let's go brandon tell us about yourself
tell us your story and then we'll get
into it
oh man i'll try and give the the short
version but uh yeah i grew up
uh great family middle class family um
i was big into sports so i played like
three sports in high school
ended up getting fortunate enough to get
a golf scholarship to play in college
it was always my dream and goal to be a
professional golfer
um my sort of in my last couple years i
had some injuries and got a little bit
burnt out
and so that was sort of like my my first
failure in life i had always just
blocked everything else out to make this
dream come true it didn't happen and i
was kind of at the end of school like
you know hadn't really paid much
attention in school and i was like you
know what am i going to do
i love sports so i went to go work for
the arizona diamondbacks i got a sales
job
i was making 100 phone calls a day um
which was actually sort of a blessing i
just learned so much about people and
rejection and
things that ended up paying off later on
in business um and when i was out there
i became friends with a lot of the guys
on the team so i was you know 22 23
years old
and they were all drinking pedialyte the
baby hydration drink
i was always into like health and
optimization and
being at your best in order to perform
whether it was in business or in school
or in sports
and i just thought it was silly that the
best athletes in the world were drinking
a drink that was designed for little
kids
and so i started studying the science of
it's called oral rehydration therapy
which i won't get too sciency but
when you mix sodium glucose and
potassium it helps water absorb your
bloodstream much much faster
and it was actually being used by the
world health organization the science
in underdeveloped countries around the
world to save lives from dehydration
so when i learned about all this i was
like what other products are leveraging
this here in the united states and
helping you know adults
you know live their best you know live
their best life and at the time you know
like about 10 years ago
there was nothing and so i i told my my
parents i was
moving home and i was gonna go get my
mba and it gave me about a year to
to study and when in reality i was um i
was
uh starting the business i got the
business off the ground in the library
uh where i went to college i just sat in
there for hours upon hours
got the business off the ground and then
um
see how many years ago see there's good
usage for college
see i leveraged their library that's
exactly right
um yeah so i gave it gave me a year to
sort of get
some wings because i just knew my
parents probably wouldn't be
you know they would always support me
but the the more traditional path was
more comfortable obviously
um so when i finally told them they
still wanted me to go
so i i i applied to i got into schools
like nyu boston college i deferred for a
year
and it gave me another year to work on
the business and by year two
i had investors a few uh angel investors
wanting to give me money and the
investor said
you can't go to school you need to run
this full time you know i'll pay you a
small salary
which then gave me the leverage to to
say hey guys i'm not going to go
go to school so i have a really slow
growth story everyone thinks we are this
like overnight success but from 2012
to 2018 we did under a million dollars
in sales in total
um i we got into whole foods in 2015 i
would sell one stick at a time every
weekend i would
sell it sell it in and then go sample
and demo product by myself
i'd go to local health stores grocery
stores
liquor stores i would tell the owner i
had one newspaper article that they
wrote about us
i said put this on your shelf they put
it on by the front for free i said here
just take it for free
if it sells call me next week and i'd
have all my friends go
by and then they'd send me venmo
requests
and i'd pay for it so i was losing free
product and paying for it myself
and it wasn't because it was a you know
it was a mini growth hack but
essentially
the when people tried it they loved it
but you have to you have to
have the marketing and backing to give
it some time to get off the ground and
so
those few weeks and that first
impression with these store owners
allowed them to then like it and they
gave me time to actually get real
marketing going so
yeah the the sort of the end story to
take you to now is like
from 2012 to 2017-18 we did under a
million in sales
um we then quickly jumped to three
brandon can i ask you a question
yeah i mean this is amazing right and
it's funny because gary and i were
talking to the hundreds uh a couple
weeks ago and they did exactly the same
thing first time they got into retail
they got their friends to go and buy
i don't think they venmo them so maybe
they own some money for that but
tell us about something 2012 2018. 17.
you did a million in total revenue but
you kept going what kept you going
i get asked that question i think i just
uh hold on i apologize because i know
it's a branded question
did you say a million in total in
combination of five years we did a total
of under a million in revenue
and by the time by the time we well no
no really
the reason i'm jumping in and bryn's
getting way better answer
but i'm but i'm gonna i just i jumped in
not to interrupt him but i jumped in to
flatter him
um because he's a real businessman and
entrepreneur
the and this is an important moment this
is my only moment to shine so i had to
jump in
we live in a framework now where people
are using these proxies that are not
real
how much money did you raise you know
you know there's so much money being
printed the trillions that america just
printed for stimulus is now in the
market
where do you think that's going like it
like there's so much money
why did he keep going because he didn't
go out of business
kept it alive and because he liked it
yeah i loved it sorry go ahead
i believe well i also the hard part is
if you play the comparison game right
like we have
some mutual friends where and i'll get
into how we got into direct to consumer
later but i
direct consumer friends like jake from
movement and other guys like that who
did
you know they went from three to 75
million in their first four years and
in my first four years we had we had
just surpassed 300 000 in revenue right
so
if you're playing the comparison game
it's a lot different but i believed in
what we were doing i loved what i was
super passionate clearly about what i
was doing
and so we built such a foundational
business where it was so strong from the
bottom it was grassroots we had sticks
in people's hands we had an incredible
culture we grew it the right way
we didn't raise a lot of capital at all
that by the time
we actually had this hockey stick start
to happen in 2018 2019
you know we went from under a million to
hundreds of millions
uh you know by the time we got acquired
in 2020
when i think that's that's exactly it
right like what gary was saying what you
were saying
the comparison game and what people are
hearing out there
is what [ __ ] people up where they go
i'm only doing 200 000 in revenue [ __ ]
that i'm gonna go do something else i'm
not making any money
but to your point and i did the same
thing until we had our exit
with gary and company like it was a very
slow growth and my entire
point as yours brandon and gary's was
like i just want to keep this thing
afloat
because i know i'm building something
and i don't care if i'm making any money
right now i mean i didn't want to make
money out other people were making a lot
more money than i did
but i'm like the fact that i can keep
this thing going like what i would look
at is like
i've got enough business to be able to
support payroll for the next six months
and that was my thing it wasn't like i'm
gonna take money out of this
i invested in brandon's company a couple
years ago
and it was the only investment i made in
like a two year period because i'd
stopped investing
and we met yeah and i remember literally
in my head
saying i'm going to regret not doing
this this is
because i i stopped investing because i
realized what i was doing wrong which
was
i was investing in companies and i
promised myself i was done with that and
i was going to go back to why i invested
in facebook twitter and tumblr when i
was on fire
and why the mistake i made with travis
on uber
is i got i became a vc instead of gary
vaynerchuk
and i said i'm going back and it's going
to happen with tick tock
excuse me with uh with mick mac with
rachel
right that one i invested in the human
and i remember i'm i'm 20 minutes in
with brandon and i need a lot of high
energy excited about their business
people i'm one of those people
and the reason people have cynicism for
me is the reason that a lot of people
passed on brandon too is
you don't really know when you meet that
energy if this is the
eight out of ten completely full of [ __ ]
one
or the two out of ten like [ __ ] this is
a big one right
and i remember being in the meeting and
asking some business i just remember it
i actually
you know the maya angelou thing you
remember what you feel not like couldn't
tell you a word of the meeting
can tell you everything my body felt and
i was a hundred percent positive
and i invested and and
it's what i want everybody because i'm
reading the comments
please love your game because if you
love your like
that's why i think i got emotional when
you when you said what kept you going
i'm like he had no choice he liked it
too much
of course outside the validation didn't
matter he liked it too much
he liked it too much he believed in his
mission he liked it too much and he was
capable enough he didn't go out of
business
a lot of people like it and go out of
business and most people are doing it
for all the wrong reasons
like for everybody who's in here right
now trying to be an entrepreneur wanting
to be an entrepreneur
um please please you know
do it because you like it so much you
know a lot of people in the comments
right now
saying some unfortunate news it's now
confirmed that dmx has passed
right the reason people are so emotional
about dmx is
he had passion for his thing as an
artist and you feel that
there's a lot of people that go into the
rap game for the money
just like entrepreneurship and i think
for a lot of people right now
like if you truly love your game then
you won't worry if you have a blue check
mark you won't worry if you have a
million followers you won't worry if
you're doing a million dollars you just
won't you won't it's like skiing
do you play golf like what i i use
golfing skiing a lot brandon play golf
for a lot of different reasons but like
most people play golf because that's the
thing they choose to do that's their
escapism they like it
you ski because they escape they like it
they swim
they play tennis they go out at night
they go to the club they watch sports
they play video games
for me i'm trying to push the
conversation of can you make that your
business because if you feel the same
way about going
skiing for a weekend as you do waking up
monday morning for your thing which is
how i live my life
and i see it in others everything
changes
all the good [ __ ] happens gary we talked
about it on your podcast but like
you know from that story of you carrying
your friends like wine out to their car
and like
for me it you know similar not as
physical as that but
you know it wasn't even like i wasn't
worried that all my friends who had
their college degrees and were making a
hundred
thousand a year and going on vacations
and stuff i was so
tunnel vision and i was so passionate
about what i was building and i
i just knew somehow i was gonna win
there was just i wasn't gonna not win
right and so
the tunnel vision is what allowed me not
to play the comparison game too much
and i just i loved it and i i knew we
were gonna figure out a way to win and i
think you i mean we talked about it you
had the same exact feeling
i totally understand
you mean no i'm remembering now and i
think this is a good lesson for everyone
else where
there's opportunity you got to strike
wild iron's hot
brandon in january 2018 in vegas
we met i think at the same time you met
as well gary the three of us were there
and then brandon talked to me and goes
hey man i've got this opportunity do you
want to invest
and i didn't follow up and i didn't
invest so liquid iv is my travis uber
story
i love it eat it soupy and right in your
[ __ ] mouth oh i
i [ __ ] eat it every day
but but i'm i'm blessed
it's the best and and and just the way
you know travis right like it's
that's what it's about like at the end
of the day the opportunity to come and
go uh it's so much more fun to tell that
story
from the losing side than the winners
for you for you it will be too because
you're a young man you're brilliant
we have a great friendship there will be
many many many many more opportunities
brandon tell us a little bit you
mentioned something um
that i want to focus in on um
folks that you were friends with folks
that um
that you were spending time with started
direct to consumer businesses and had an
in
like hockey stick instantly right you
went a different path
you went down to retail big box path
and it brought different things with it
right tell us about that approach
and why that was different and in many
ways better
um than going straight direct to
consumer
yeah i mean there's a lot of ways to win
right and for me i just knew my skill
set
right like i wasn't like a developer
who was like amazing at running facebook
ads like that just wasn't my skill set i
was a people person
i developed some incredible
relationships through sports
um i developed an incredible issue with
someone uh gary knows scott emerson
who plays the the big box game as well
and so it was just sort of i matched
what i was what i knew i was good at
which was
going to these retail meetings
explaining to them why our product would
work we were this total white space
they'd never heard of a hydration
category they wanted to put us in
sports nutrition or diet or beverage and
i was like
i don't care where you put us i'm going
to drive people into the store and
they're going to buy the product and so
yeah i mean it worked well for us based
on my skill set as the leader
um because i knew that we could win that
way and so we did we built the business
super grassroots that way and then
what was so cool is you know my my
my dad always says aces and spaces like
my aces was
getting these big big box relationships
figuring out how to raise the proper
amount of money to support inventory to
launch
and then i found experts like you guys
and that's when i called you know i met
you guys in vegas and i
sat with gary there and i sat with you
and you guys came in and ran you know
built our website and gary's team helped
run all of our dtc and so
you know and of course i knew enough to
be dangerous in that area
but like i picked what my sweet spot was
and then i found experts around
me to build that up and what was so cool
is like because we had done it that way
by the time we did go direct to consumer
and amazon which was a big part of it
you know there was all these people that
already tried the product so it made the
you know the acquisition costs and
everything that they dropped a lot
because of that
um and the other thing is like what was
so cool about building such a
well-rounded business and not being so
one-dimensional whether it was only in
store or online
so for example when covet hit you know
we didn't know what was going to happen
it was march of 2020 the world turns
upside down all retail shots
that was half but you know that's a lot
of our business but we had a huge amazon
business and direct consumer and all
those customers started buying online
and then once stores opened up like
costco which was a big customer of ours
that
that business went right back up to
where it was or higher and our direct
consumer business never dropped so
our plan in 2020 was a massive growth
plan we were going to double our sales
in 2020
and what we ended up doing in 2020 was
double our aggressive growth plan and it
was because we had this omni-channel
business that was so foundational
and we didn't we weren't just
one-dimensional we we focused on being
balanced and there were so many people
in the beginning of the business we're
like
only focus on one type of customer you
can't market to everybody
and only on one channel and i was like i
hear you the textbooks say that but
liquid iv is for everybody and i believe
i rather grow it slowly over 10 years
and have all these channels
so when [ __ ] hits the fan like kovid
when all these businesses or don't know
what to do
we had all these things to balance the
business out so i'm grateful
i trusted my gut and went with it's for
everybody and we're going in all
channels which
not necessarily is the smartest thing
but it works really well for us
i'm i'm a big believer in that soupy and
i think i think
early in my career at wine library
somebody said to me
gary the wine business is around
selection price and service
and to be successful and this was the
guy who had the biggest distributor
company
hundreds of millions of dollars i'm 22
years old it's our first lunch meeting
and he goes you got a lot of talent you
know know your dad for a long time
and i because i've been in the store
since i was 14. this is me kind of like
coming of age
he goes you're gonna have to pick two of
the three to be successful
i didn't say anything six years later
there was like this huge new york times
article written about me like building
the biggest
wine store in the country so fast kid
and i told the story
and i didn't mention him by name and i
said and i remember
him saying that and i remember walking
back to the store because it was close
to store
and saying that's the stupidest advice
i've ever heard why won't i just deliver
on price
service and selection the guy wrote me a
letter
he goes read the article unbelievably
goes i have a bad feeling i know who
that person was
congratulations and i think the point
there that brandon was making for a lot
of people in the chat right now
we're listening after we record this
too many people listen to people that
have done it before them
the mark the market changes people are
different
people have different strengths and
weaknesses dynamics change the context
has changed
one of the reasons that i don't think i
share my passions i don't think that i'm
giving advice or should be listened to
why because there's too many nuances on
the person on the other side of it
for me to actually give advice is when
me and brandon actually spoke
zubin when you and i actually have
meetings give me all the context
i'll do the best i can to give good
advice pattern recognition good intent
but gary be the character i'm trying to
share my passions
and hypotheses and general nuances that
i see
but it's not actual advice because the
human on the other side of it
needs to give too much context for that
story to be advised and for everybody
who's listening
me everybody else in the world your
parents brandon to be like
you have to contextualize it to you but
you have to contextualize it from
optimism
not from like excuses to why not because
then
when you're being cynical and being in
no culture or negative culture or
spewing negativities
your game is over already and i don't
think it's bad to listen to
people who have done it before like i i
listen to a lot of people have done
before
i think the key to that is to put it
through your own filter
correct and contextualize it for
yourself and say hey that was from this
generation
what you know what from that relates to
me and then sometimes you listen and use
all of it
sometimes you use none of it and i think
that's why like people always ask about
mentors i think they're great
but you have to contextualize it to
yourself and your filter and your
you know your life for your business you
know
yep absolutely i think that um
that it's really interesting we in some
ways
when you look back at the liquid iv
journey
now with exit and we'll get there in a
moment but if you look back like the
first five
seven years eight years you're like look
it's a slow burn everybody's going fast
but i think one of the things and and
there's a lot to be learned here for
everyone
who's tuning in one of the things that
we were blown away
um so as an agency we met with a bunch
of different
uh brands right that were at a certain
point they wanted to blow up their
direct to consumer et cetera so we meet
with them
um robbie dicks and i walked out of the
meeting with you brandon
and we're like [ __ ] this is really
interesting because
they have the kind of
the expertise the energy everything
around all these direct consumer brands
we meet with
but what they have that many of those
don't have
is like operational wherewithal they've
shipped millions of products they've
done this
they've [ __ ] up uh from a supply chain
standpoint they've gone through all that
where like so many of these brands that
just go hockey stick up
i mean you all know they will run out of
inventory they won't have this they
won't have that there's so many issues
that happen
that like you had a legit business you
had a solid business
once you decided to like focus in on
direct consumer again
my point isn't that everybody should do
that it's not for everyone and they
won't be able to succeed frankly if they
want to do that
but your ability to do that
gave you kind of a moat created that
mode for you and gave you an advantage
that others didn't have
and i think that's really the
interesting part that's like to your
earlier point
take whatever path you want but
understand that at the end of the day
and this is what everyone's realizing
that it requires a
multi-channel approach to be successful
but but i will say this for people who
are listening who are
very early in their journey brandon's
capability for that kind of distribution
and then that street
dirt four years of entrepreneurship to
make it successful
box by box because he was on he was
scaling unscalable behavior
is really the only way to win
big box and that's if you're even lucky
enough to be able to get into big box
so the reality is is that 97 to 98
percent of people listening right now
are going to start dtc and
they're and to your point zoom in i i
think this still keeps coming down to
just
brandon's a good businessman and and
rachel's a good businesswoman at mcmack
and and like
i hope we get back to that it's not just
about raising money
doing facebook arbitrage like the
conversation of being
a good businessman or woman i'm almost
starting i can't believe what i just
said
i'm starting to realize i'm thinking
about the same way i don't use hustle
anymore because it's been manipulated
and now i use work ethic is one of the
things that matter
i'm starting to think that i'm going to
start using business man and woman
more than entrepreneur because i think
the word's been manipulated
and understood to be something else like
you have to be good at business
this is business yeah i mean you guys
have been through it as much as anybody
but
there's so many dark times or hard times
where
if you didn't have that extra gear
inside of you to go win
so it would have felt folded over and
that's why
even as i'm getting hit up now all the
time for different investment
opportunities
it truly and hearing you say that
actually helps me because i'm kind of
trying to figure out my own thesis with
that
but it comes down to the the
entrepreneur the businessman and woman
who are leading because it's just that
little extra bit of
effort waking up at 4am to whiteboard
like whatever it is to figure that thing
out like
that is the win like this
and two things uzi ddc stands direct to
consumer it's a term we use in
e-commerce
and brandon that's what goes back to my
earlier point
which was you're not waking up at four
o'clock if you're doing it for the lambo
you're not you're not calling a customer
and apologizing and driving to their
house and saying sorry if you don't
worry about your reputation because
you're gonna do business forever
like this goes back to tried and true
good kind
real authentic realities of life
that will be the sustained model in the
supply and demand of as many businesses
that are out there and i you know i i
think that
i just can't get this out of my stomach
anymore if you don't like it you're not
going to pull it off
and yes do some people frantically that
chase money pull it off they do
but i know those people you know what
happens they become even more miserable
with the money they start doing terrible
[ __ ]
you know this brand you run in the la
circles like they there is like
there's it's star wars there's the jedis
and the dark side and both
can win to a point but jedis will always
win so they can have sustainable lives
right the dark side that's about it for
the money they
do it for the insecurity they can pull
it off too because that energy is high
darth vader's [ __ ] powerful
but what happens is when they get the
bag
it gets really dark it does and it gets
and like that's what i don't want like
there's people here who
may say ah gary's phil you know i hear
it i hear it from the dark jedi he's
like [ __ ] gary he's too foofy you know i
get drilled on both sides
gary you know like i'm losing on both
sides like he's two entrepreneurs on the
other side
the entrepreneurs are mad at me because
i'm saying too much foofy [ __ ]
and i'm just like [ __ ] lonely out
here but i'm like fine
but like it gets bad brandon it gets bad
like
when when i heard your exit i felt such
calmness
i'm like that's a base for a lot of good
stuff i
i've seen some exits to contemporaries
acquaintances investments
even lightweight friends and i go into
immediate anxiety
because i know the next two years is
going to be not good
and i just hope they can get out of it
and i've had those combos and they don't
want to hear it
they don't want to hear it it's hard
yeah
look i think that
two thoughts one it's cliche to say it's
about the
journey not the destination but anyone
who's done sales anyone has
anything like that to gary's point
you'll realize
at a tactical level you get super
excited right before the sale
you get that sale and then what right
that adrenaline rush is gone
because you're not enjoying the every
day of it
and then you're going back down into a
valley and then you got to go back up
so look it's about sustainable happiness
i think
going back to your point good
businessmen good businesswoman
and i think that if we're talking about
again rachel
and brandon what you realize very
quickly
is that they're good people that they're
good solid
characters they have solid business
fundamentals so the gary's point doesn't
matter where they start
d2c big box whatever they
get business they work hard but they're
solid
characters and so yeah and and they
and they have that gear oh yeah
that gear that i call it's that scene in
the movie where
like the hero gets punched in the face
hard
and you think he's gonna get like
knocked out or not knocked out and they
kind of like go there and they spit out
the blood
and maybe even a tooth and they look
back at you
and then the bad guy is like oh [ __ ]
that's the thing i'm looking for right
you know i knew in that moment in vegas
that if brandon got punched in the
[ __ ] face
he would spit the blood out spit the
tooth out
look back at you and be like now you're
in [ __ ] trouble
i felt that about rachel i feel that
about myself
and i think that's what that's that
little thing right there
that's the weird one that's the nine
figure exits
the ten figure exits the the eight
figure consistency business that kicks
get like
this is sports this is [ __ ] sports
frankly frankly like that when that
moment happens and in 2020 there are a
lot of those
there's some weird thing inside of me
like i think a lot of good leaders and
entrepreneurs when things are going good
can roll with the momentum and keep it
going but there's something when like
the greatest challenges hit us like in
march of 2020
or you know during the summer of 20 i
mean the whole year
where like some extra thing happens
where i'm like now it's time
for me to even stop it more make sure i
leave my team and bring positive light
to our community like
that is the moment where the best the
actual real winners
step up the most you know there's a
martin luther king quote about like in
times of
you know in easy times you know it
anyone can lead through it it's the
times of darkness and despair where
true character comes out and i think
that is that extra gear if you can see
that in someone
it's it's pretty cool it's pretty cool i
think it's very cool i got to run to
another live thing thank you
thank you team i'll let you know bye
everybody who's watching just to give
everyone a sense brandon i think like
gary and i keep talking about you and
your character
but people listening and don't know you
um i think one thing will give them a
clear indication
how much more did it mean to you to
make so many people that are your close
friends and family
to make them winners to make them
kind of financially successful from your
exit how much more did it mean
to you for that to happen than for you
to become
financially successful out of it yeah
personally
i i for myself i was doing it because i
wanted the business to win
but the thing that was probably the most
gratifying which has taken me
literally six months to sort of like
comprehend and get my feet on the ground
is
you know i had 80 friends family
investors like gary but i had like you
know my mom my sister
my dad you know close friends who
had no money who gave me like five
thousand dollars in the beginning of the
business like whatever they had to give
me
and you know five six years later that
turned into a seven figure check or more
right and so i honestly because i was
going through my own transition
it's like a very uh sort of extreme
transition right i lived in an 800
square foot apartment for seven years
and then like we get the sale and i'm
able to buy a house and it's just this
really weird dynamic it's hard to
comprehend but when i think about like
one of my goals you know not to get too
much into my family background but my
parents were divorced and my mom
you know my goal was always i wanted to
get her a house that she would love
and so with the sale the company with
the proceeds she made and then me being
able to help her we got her this you
know awesome house that she now loves
and she's comfortable in and you know
she's not in this small apartment here
in l.a anymore and
like that was probably of all the things
that was that was one of the most
meaningful and
then the other one is like when i look
around and like probably the
15 or 20 people in my closest circle who
were connected to live
the live leadership team my family my
friends literally everyone's buying a
house
and not that that's like anything but
it's the most tangible thing to be like
wow all that ridiculous hard work
allowed
like my close circle to be able to like
you know
uh you know see out this dream that they
all had to be homeowners it's just
really cool it's
it's just one example but it's like for
me it's the most tangible where i can
like
comprehend what all that nine years of
hard work equated to for all these
people who believed in me when they
probably shouldn't have
well they believed in you because they
knew why you were doing it
they believed in you because of
everything gary mentioned and ultimately
that like what you were able to achieve
with the folks that you worked with for
everyone around you
is what will keep you happy forever
right that's your sustainable happiness
that's what i think again people like
gary
are incredibly well
attuned to understanding other people
like
gary's thing i think one of the things
that his his biggest strength
if you ask me is his ability to
quickly make an opinion an informed
opinion about somebody
whether i mean whatever he that opinion
is right
but he gets an understanding because he
sees so many people he's got so much
care
um pattern recognition in that sense
that he sees it
he saw that in you he wasn't investing
in anything else he invested in this
because he knew that and
ultimately i think like the point i'm
trying to drive here is that
there it's more than just that exit it's
more than just that growth it's about
that journey and it's about ultimately
once you get that exit
not what it can do for you but what it
did for everyone around you that'll keep
you
happy forever it's true it's true
what do you think about your upbringing
led you to
um caring so much about making those
around you successful
yeah i'm i think about it a lot because
you know i've been reading
just a lot of books on like some of the
you know best leaders or entrepreneurs
of all time like
you know benjamin franklin or albert
einstein or elon musk
like you read these biographies about
like how they became who they are right
and i'm like
how did like how did i become the way i
am i'm like so curious and so
i just been so fortunate my parents you
know they loved me a ton which i think
is key but
um my dad you know he he
worked in a dairy shop his dad's dairy
shop in the lower east side of new york
he carried a knife when he was like 13
and he was supposed to take over that
dairy shop and his dad when his dad was
i had was sick with cancer and my dad my
dad was 20.
he said move to l.a follow your dreams
as an architect and
he did and his whole family wanted to
take over the dairy shop and he didn't
he ignored all of that
and so he came out here with nothing and
he started at an architecture room with
200 people
and now 30 40 years later he's the ceo
of a six thousand person
company and so like he put this chip on
my shoulder he wasn't a ceo while i was
growing up he was just grinding and
working
but he put this chip on my shoulder
growing up that was like you gotta work
for everything
every single thing you gotta work for
and so i i was fortunate enough to have
a good upbringing
but because he put this ship on my
shoulder number one i was just like
i'm gonna outwork everybody no matter
what the other thing he would always
have me recite this and
it sounds kind of corny but when i think
back to these hard times i've gone
through i always knew this was true
he would say he would have me recite him
like like if you set your mind to it
anything is possible and i would just
like repeat it to him and i was like dad
i know i got it i got it
but when it came to like these hard
things like i truly believe when i write
it on my whiteboard and i start to think
through it
i really believe i can make it happen so
i think you know that that on my dad's
side from a business perspective is
great
and my mom is just this incredibly
empathetic person like
she cares so much about everybody she
took care of us she sacrificed her
career to take care of me my sister
i think when you combine her incredible
interpersonal sort of
intangible skills of people with my
dad's business and leadership
i sort of feel like this incredible
gratitude that i like got these
sometimes it's a strength and a weakness
right sometimes i'm so empathetic it's
hard
but i think when you combine like you
know the sort of like get down to
business like how do we win aside from
my dad and this super empathetic side
from my mom
it created this sort of like how you
know how i think about things i care
about people but i also want to win in
business because i know
if the business wins it's going to help
more people around the world you know
no that's amazing and i think like the
type of person that you are
you would rather lose out on a business
opportunity
than hurt someone else right like it's
like that and
yes you might make certain business
decisions that
or that are favor people
right that don't necessarily favor the
bottom line
but ultimately i think you would be uh
it would be difficult for you to
reconcile if you made
the other type of decision yeah and
clearly it worked out well for you
i i mean you if there's a um
good people i can make it just on good
people but if it's just good business
and bad people
it's written like i've done it a few
times and it just has never turned out
well like
like doing business with good people is
just like almost like a baseline
like they have to have that and then all
of the business has to be there as well
but like
it's not fun to be in business with
people that are not sort of like morally
or ethically sound you know
i'm 100 with you and i think at the same
time it's also difficult
um having gone through it myself as well
and i know you have as well is like
working with people that you care about
that are a wrong fit yeah and it gets to
a point where you're like look
i love this person but if i
don't remove this person from this
equation 20 other people are going to
get [ __ ]
yeah and i what i the way it's helped me
because those are that's really hard as
a leader when you care about something
but the way i think about it is it's for
the greater good of
all of our customers out there it's for
the greater good of the rest of the team
the integrity of the business and the
team
and frankly if it's not working for the
business of the team
whether the person knows it or not
there's a better opportunity out there
for them where they're going to be a
better fit and be happier so
it took me a while i was you know i was
young i was 24 25 26 when i had to sort
of learn all this but
as i've matured and learned this like
i've seen i've seen people where we have
to let them go
and they're now in such a much better
position right and i love them and i
cared about them but
now they're on to some place where they
truly belong and they're in that
environment where they're winning right
so
but it takes leadership and courage to
make those hard decisions sometimes you
know
yeah absolutely i mean i think there's
uh
you're reminding me of a story we ended
up
um when we were growing our engineering
team we needed like a back-end engineer
couldn't find anyone
in southern california and we found a
gentleman in rhode island
and seemed like a really good fit but he
had to move his family out
and so we're like okay we need to like
do some extra like digging to make sure
like give him tests whatever we need to
he comes out with his whole family moves
out six
eight weeks and we realize it's not a
good fit and
i literally remember having to tell him
this and we tried whatever we could and
it just didn't work out
it was the most difficult
day we've had clients we've lost
everything all sorts of stuff but the
most difficult day in my career was the
day where we had to lay him off
and it i mean i i'll get emotional just
talking about it but
thankfully he's in a much better place
now much better than if he would have
stayed with us
and ultimately like what we did
and and this isn't to say like oh we're
great people we did this it's not about
that at all it's just a matter of like
how you deal with people
what we did is we basically said look
we're gonna give you four weeks notice
but what we're gonna do is we're gonna
actively we've got an hr department
we're gonna find you a position
we found a position in two weeks he went
off he's doing brilliantly now
but for me as the leader of the
organization that was the most difficult
thing i did and the only thing that got
me through it
was knowing that he would land in a
better place because imagine it's not
just one person you move this whole
family out here
yeah it's brutal it is
yeah i think as a leader
i think that the hardest thing by far
from and i think it's different for
different leaders but for my type
of personality like losing business
i can totally deal with that that's like
on me i can deal
it's having to like look someone in the
face and let them go is probably the
hardest thing but
having that foresight that you know that
if it's not working if it's not working
for
the business it's not working for them
whether they know it or not you know
it's these difficult decisions the whole
reason i'm bringing this up is because
you go through
brandon his journey has probably gone
through a hundred two hundred thousand
difficult decisions
but i think the key if you were to ask
me and uh
maybe brandon will agree is being able
to make those difficult decisions
as quickly as you can because the longer
they take
the more damage it can cause yeah yeah i
mean i think
there's there's a part of it where you
have to pull as much information as you
can
right and then you make the best
educated decision with the information
that you have and
i think for me what's helped us and some
of those i've made wrong decisions
absolutely i mean tons of them right
but i think like you make it and i but i
know i make that
i've made bad decisions but i've never
had any regrets and it's because
at that moment i took all of the data
that i had and i made the best possible
decision now
whether it was right or wrong you figure
that out you learn from it and you move
forward and i think
that's part of this i just like always
keep moving forward what's next
how do we learn it's either a winning
decision great we got all the credit
awesome or
it's not and as long as you learn from
and you analyze what was
you know what didn't work then you left
you utilize that knowledge in that
acumen in the future
absolutely and i just want to comment on
something jc in the comments
um wrote couldn't you have just worked
uh couldn't he have just worked for you
remotely and not move this whole family
jc this was like in 2010 or 11 where
if you want to get a sense of how
different times were then i would go to
work every day
with a tie on literally for 10 years i
wore a tie
every day to work whether i had a
meeting or not so remote work was
[ __ ] out of the question i
like i had to go to the office every day
i would fly across the country for 15
minute meetings
now it's like i'll do i'll do four of
those in an hour on
zoom and everyone's okay with it it's
just a totally different time
but i think one of the one of the um
advantages here and we're talking about
like
being honest with people when you hire
them being honest with people when
you have to part ways with them part of
the challenge i think that companies had
like liquid ivy like we did is you only
have the talent pool around you before
so you would basically sometimes have to
embellish
what you're doing to get the best talent
or you'd have to just deal with somebody
who's
kind of a partial fit but what basically
what's happened over the last year to
brandon's point
is you can now within reason like
recruit people anywhere
have them work anywhere and find really
the best fit for your company
not somebody who's just down the street
it's true
totally it's a it's a whole i mean we're
still you know while i was still running
the business like we were still trying
to figure out that balance because
i think there's a lot of magic that
happens in person i think collaboration
and
especially on the creative side of
things like the way creative things come
about is by collaboration and an idea
comes out of nowhere and so
i think there's still value in that but
there's also all these huge benefits to
finding the best talent around the
country or the world remote
and you know being able to bring them on
and uh
yeah there's there's efficiencies on
both sides so i think you know the way
that i think the way things are gonna go
moving forward is
there's gonna be this balance of both
right you're able to take the best of
both worlds in person remote
um and really make it work so many the
um the big companies that i know that
would
never allow anyone to work remotely like
it would have to be like a
once in a blue moon you can work on a
friday because you've got to go to a
doctor's office
are moving to exactly the model the
brandon's talking about where they're
changing their
space they're going from x number of
square feet to
one-tenth of that or one-fifth of that
and then
going into an environment where people
can come in once or twice a week
collaborate
it's like their social zone if you will
because you want to see people in person
but at the end of the day
many people have learned to become
incredibly productive
at home um and it's not for everyone i
totally understand that but
that that hybrid solution i think is
going to be interesting
so brandon let's get back to business
for a moment so you go from
doing several hundred thousand dollars
in revenue
in 1718 to
exiting just a few years later
can you talk to us about that growth how
did it happen how did you meet unilever
just
give us that story yeah um
you know like i said we built this super
foundational business which allowed for
for a quick scale i think a lot of
businesses would struggle to scale like
we did but because we had the right
partners and resources and culture and
team
it allowed us to um 2019 was like
probably like the really inflection
point here where we were doing
tens of millions you know two years
later two years earlier we were doing
under a million
doing tens of millions um in 2019
we did this sort of celebrity investment
round which was the round that gary came
in on
um and it sort of just like gave us a
lot of credibility that
although we you know we already had it
in the product it sort of gave us the
awareness that we were maybe not
lacking but it just elevated everything
a lot faster
you know a lot of our retail doors we
had incredible partnerships like with
costco and walmart and things like that
you know between that and then our
direct to consumer and amazon business
really
you know uh growing up as fast or faster
than the in-store business
as we went into 2020 and we didn't know
the pandemic was going to hit
we thought you know this is probably a
really sort of
strategic time to maybe look for a big
partner and the reason was
not necessarily to exit because of the
the you know the capital reasons but
there was all these opportunities that
we were getting that we couldn't
we didn't have the resources to take on
we couldn't grow fast enough we're at 50
people we've grown a ton
and it was like we were only in the us
we weren't even you know when you have a
consumer product there's so much
regulatory stuff you have to do with
um you know with going international and
things like that and we wanted to hold
it tight to what we knew
but we were getting opportunities from
canada and from europe and from
australia
and asia and we're like what if we could
have a partner come on
take out a lot of that like there was so
much risk from
founders and the early investors in the
team like
you know we were we weren't paying
ourselves the right amount like we were
like really really lean
and so we thought it could be a win-win
where it gives the business a chance to
scale globally
you know be able to create a better
product for the end consumer and take
care of a lot of the key employees and
investors who
you know hadn't seen any money back in
it you know five six seven eight years
right and
even for me like i was you know i was
living on a
extremely tight i didn't care but it was
just a tight budget just because all i
cared about was the business so
at the end of 2019 we decided it might
be a good time to start looking we went
through a process we you know
i've been getting hit up for a while
like we have people always hitting us up
they
hey we'd love to talk to you about
acquiring you or you know different
times of
different types of investment
opportunities and we just thought it was
the right time and
we went through a process that was super
competitive in 2020 just to give context
on 2020 how crazy it was
we go remote in march no idea how to run
a remote business
like i've only run one business and i've
never done a remote no idea how to do
that in high remote
all of our stores close for two weeks
then they reopen and everyone buys
everything off the shelf
like clean dry our dtc business is
growing
and then you come into the summer which
was you know
for us because you know we have an
extremely diverse team and like you know
uh it's really important to us all the
social things that were going on in the
world over the summer in may june july
with george floyd
and we that that was another just really
challenging like to try and lead through
that in the right way and to make sure
we're supporting our team in the right
way
and then behind the scenes that entire
time well the business is doubling our
aggressive growth plan
and then behind the scenes i'm i'm
talking to all these large like the
biggest corporations in the world about
potentially acquiring us that i couldn't
talk about with anybody not my friends
not my team and so it was just like just
the
absolute perfect storm of craziness and
i think that's where
sort of like the calm and composure and
like
this is my time to just like be the best
possible leader that i can
so fast forward to september the
business is still doing incredibly
you know i sort of relate to my team
what what we're going to be doing and
why
they support us and me completely and in
october
after sort of narrowing it down we
announced that uh we're getting acquired
by unilever which is sort of like
um you know it's kind of like this dream
as an entrepreneur like i never really
knew what the exit would be or if there
would be one but
you know you get this massive win where
there's it's one of the first times
where you actually can realize the value
individually for all these people for
what what you've created and so
yeah it was it was a ridiculous year but
it was also so special at the same time
brandon tell us about that process so
you're meeting with large corporations
obviously you start that in 2020
um how long did that process take with
unilever and why unilever
it's probably it was almost a full year
it's almost a full year process it's a
long process there's a lot of there's a
lot of people involved in a lot of
different
things to check down um
for us we had some other off options on
the table that
were maybe even for more you know bigger
deals
but it came down to like what did we
think the best
where could liquidity have the best
opportunity to become the biggest best
awesome global brand and
unilever has a lot of sustainability uh
initiatives and for me that's huge like
that's a big part of what i'm passionate
about is like
the world and making sure that we leave
it better than we found it and so
you know finding a home where they would
let us go keep doing our thing they had
the right sort of guiding principles
that align with ours
um is why we ended up going with them
and yeah it was a
it was a long process and i feel like we
found the best home for like would i be
that's amazing um brandon a couple more
questions for you and we really
appreciate your time on today um
there was a question in the chat from
francisco ortiz when did you start
taking a salary
um we started in 2012 i i think i
we i first took a salary in 2014 i've
hit myself 20 20 000
that year and then how did you scale
that up for yourself
uh i paid myself as little as i possibly
could because i'd save some money from
my first job
because i didn't want to hurt the
business i wanted the business to look
as good as it could when we went to go
raise money
frankly the only time i'd raised my
salary was
when we had to go find a really really
good high level
executive like a ceo or a cfo or cmo
and they're getting paid a lot of money
and it would just look weird if the ceo
is getting paid half of what these other
leaders were getting paid so
i would always like wait until we were
about to hire a really high level
executive
and then i'd bump mine to like five
thousand dollars above that just so when
people looked at our investors looked at
our
salary table like it didn't look weird
that i was like paying myself half of
all these other people
that that's brilliant i think that a lot
of um
people and i'm sure you've seen these
sorts of uh investor decks as well
is they just bloat themselves like you
look at it you're like okay they're like
we need six months runway we're raising
x
and you look at it and most of the money
is going to salaries which
isn't an issue necessarily but it's like
you've got a
look at brandon's story like you've got
to invest your time
if you want other people to invest their
money at a certain point right
especially when you're starting out
brandon give us um what are the three
best lessons you learned
over the last 10 years
three best wow that's a lot i gotta come
up with one to start it was one
yeah oh man
three best lessons i learned i think
one is that and i think you and gary
talked about it today
which is like you can have the like
best business strategy or product or any
of these things and
truly it comes down to people and
relationships
like you it's not like you can have a
bad business and just have great
relationships because that won't work
either
but you can have a great idea and like
gary will tell you like when we were
working together there were a couple
times where things weren't
going as good as they needed to be or
even me and you right and like i
like i would pick up the phone and the
reason that
i did that was because i knew that
whether it was in that moment or three
years from now
like that relationship was gonna be
really really important so like
like just uh you know not burning
bridges and
like you never know when there's a
relationship that's gonna
that's gonna be important i think that's
why you asked the question about big box
versus dtc
it's because for the first few years out
of school for me i just
and it wasn't like some like intentional
motivation i had to
it was just these genuine relationships
i built with people who i was super
curious about they were doing or how
they were running their business or what
they were doing
and then when the time came where we
were looking for investors or we needed
a dtc partner or whatever it was
i was able to call and say hey i got
this great idea not going to burden you
with it but i think
this could be valuable for you too
always adding value to the other person
right like
i think what i've noticed lately is i
have so many entrepreneurs reach out to
me now
and i love investing and helping but a
lot of them are just like
they they don't bring value to the inve
like
they want to energy suck you and i think
when i look back on i was like how did i
get all these awesome people to get
involved
i always came to them with like
how is this going to bring value for you
like this is why i think this is a good
investment for you
or why i think we should do this
partnership and so i
probably the thing that i would hang my
hat on is like that relationships are
just so so so key
and i think you're spot on with value um
i think it's something that
that's often missed like people want to
create a product that
provides value to the consumer but then
they don't provide
organizationally enough value for their
employees they don't provide value
within their ecosystem and i think
you're spot on on that and it cannot be
understated
or overstated rather how much
how important it is to continually
create new value
and not transfer that value and make
sure that everybody that you're touching
is getting something in return
and it's not just a energy sucker like i
want this from you and i'm not going to
give you anything back but it's
reciprocal
and in your case you were able to give
enough
so much value to your employees and
vendors and whatnot that they wanted to
go to bat for you they wanted you to win
ultimately and so they wanted you to win
they wanted the consumer to win
everybody
right so from gang we keep talking about
this
it's 360 too because you can't like
i think some people think it's just
provide value to the consumer which you
absolutely have to do
but like if you don't have the team who
we always talked about
life value i want to add a life value so
yeah salary is important or
culture is important but like at the end
like at the end
people wanted to come work for liquid iv
because it was like
this cool culture we paid well
and like it was cool to work at liquid
iv because we had built this culture of
winning and accountability and all these
things like without the team behind the
scenes
who are going to go to bat and go to war
with me in these hard times
you can't provide the value to consumer
but like you got to be fighting the
value of the consumer you got to be
running value to investors and so
like i think that's what's so
interesting when people think of ceos or
entrepreneurs it's like
they're like oh you create your own
schedule it's like about you it's
actually the opposite
all i was ever thinking about was all
these different constituents whether
it's investors
or team or consumers
retailers right like if you are
providing value for all them your
business will succeed but if you're
thinking about yourself in that
situation it's just
like that's the thing you for frankly
for 10 years i sacrificed
myself for that i think that's what i'm
excited for sort of post acquisition is
to like
focus on like getting healthy and doing
some things that i just completely
blocked out for the last 10 years of my
life
yeah yeah but the irony is that you
focused on everyone else
and in return because it was authentic
and genuine
they focused on you and they made you a
better person
yep it's all about that focus um
brandon tell us what you're up to now
yeah i
uh yeah i just i i i sort of just
stepped away um a few weeks ago
um it was a hard decision but i think in
you know in totality it made so much
sense right like
my team is now in a great spot to carry
on this business we built all the
foundational pieces they need
you know unilever you know i've sort of
passed on the secret sauce to them so
they can go keep doing it
and frankly for me i just i didn't
really realize this because i only
started one business but
like i'm just like at heart i'm an
entrepreneur i'm an innovator like i
want to think i'm like outside the box
thinking of
i have you know things with
sustainability renewable energy
um so i just it was sort of like if my
my mission
maybe you know or don't but it's called
change the world like ctw
and it means like helping people
everywhere live better lives for
generations to come and
when i use that as my decision point
like unilever now can go
take this brand and make it a 10 billion
dollar global business right
my team is now in a spot to either keep
running and live or have opportunities
elsewhere because everyone loves one you
know wants a piece of our team now
and now i in my sweet spot from an
efficiency standpoint me being in that
wouldn't have been most efficient
i can go create other products and
services that are going to add value to
the world so
it was a tough decision it's like
walking away from like i'm sure when
parents send their kids to college or
something like i don't have kids yet but
i'm sure it's like that like
i spent 10 years of my life building it
and it was just like time to
to set it free and now i have some sort
of big things i can't really talk about
that i'm working on
starting to get going and in the
meantime i'm just taking some i'm trying
to
take a you know take a deep breath
because i'm a go go go kind of person
and just like
i've taken the last month to just
reflect on
sort of what the last 10 years was our
community that we built
the 80 people who you know made
life-changing wealth from this deal
and just like take a deep breath and
sort of audit myself and where i want to
go moving forward because
it would be really easy to jump into
something fast i there's a couple things
going on and so yeah i'm just sort of
taking a deep breath right now i'm sure
it won't last that long i'm trying to
like
like be as patient as possible but i'm
really really
i've never been more excited and
motivated for this next phase
you know i have resources that i never
had before like
most importantly is just the
relationships like i can call you i can
call gary
i can call my distribution partners or
my suppliers or my celebrity investors
they all are like hey what's next i'm in
what's next i'm in so
i think that's one of the most valuable
things you know because of that
credibility now and then
obviously the financial piece like i had
zero to my name
and now i have something where if i'm
when i'm ready to go i you know i can i
can really put some uh some fuel in the
engine
granted you're amazing thank you so much
for sharing your story thanks for being
such an inspiration to so many people i
think that
um i really enjoyed this i know that the
audience enjoyed it based on the
comments and
i can't wait to read your book when you
write it thanks so much man
it's really fun being on i appreciate
you having me and yeah i'm really
grateful
thanks bro see you all right see ya